MALE SPEAKER: Welcome to
Talks at Google, Chicago.
Today we're excited to announce
Frank Schaeffer joining us
for his second talk
here at Google.
He just spoke in
Cambridge last month,
and you can find them
talk on our Talks
at Google YouTube channel.
In introducing Frank,
it's hard to keep it brief
as it seems unlikely that
one person could have amassed
a resume that includes
the following-- born
into a family of prominent
evangelicals, helping found
the religious right
in the United States,
rejecting that
political point of view,
and becoming a vocal
opponent of the Tea Party;
directing slasher movies;
becoming a "New York Times"
bestselling author of both
fiction and non-fiction;
becoming a visual artist
whose work has been shown
and collected around the world;
a frequent guest on Rachel
Maddow with
appearances on "Oprah,"
"The Today Show," "Fresh
Air," and the "BBC News";
an in-demand lecturer who
has spoken at Princeton,
the Kennedy School of
Government at Harvard.
No longer a terrible father and
a pretty darn good grandfather,
but most of all, a thoughtful,
reflective observer
of the human condition and
our relation to spirituality,
religion, art, and the Universe.
Oh, yeah, one more thing-- we
left out that he survived polio
and that he also
has recently become
a member of the
Greek Orthodox Church
and many, many other things.
There just isn't enough time.
So please join me in
welcoming Frank Schaeffer.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANK SCHAEFFER: Thanks
for coming out today.
I gather I'm probably the
last speaker in this room
before you all move to your
new, even swankier offices.
But thank you so much for
having me come talk with you.
I really enjoyed the time
down in Cambridge at Google
and here as well
because as someone
who grew up as a
terminal dyslexic,
Google is one of the things that
has come to my aid as a writer.
In a weird way,
your search engine
is the only good spell
check in the world.
If I can even think of
two letters in a word,
I will eventually get there.
Whereas all the Word
stuff, without going
into too much depth,
let alone anything else,
doesn't quite work the same.
So I actually really
enjoy the possibility
of coming here and
talking with you
because you folks, this
company, has actually made
a huge difference to my life.
And one of the
ways it has changed
the way I look at things, and
then I'll get into my talk
in proper, is both
these paintings
of mine and also this book.
I've had success as an author.
I have had some "New
York Times" best sellers,
et cetera, et cetera.
But I also someone
who's gotten heartily
sick of the gatekeepers in
this culture who, for instance,
when I wrote a book called "Why
I am an Atheist Who Believes
in God," which is what I'll be
talking about a little today,
and you all have got some
copies there at the back
you can take with you that I'll
sign for you if you want them.
Going through the
routine channels,
the marketing folks from some
of the publishing companies that
have been very successful
with my books in the past
said, well, our marketing
people don't even
know what shelf to put this on.
You've got to decide who
you are and what you are.
Is this going to go on
the Christopher Hitchens
and Dawkins shelf, or is this
some sort of spirituality book
that we'll market like we
would a Deepak Chopra book?
Where's it coming from?
And of course, the whole
point of the title,
"Why I am an Atheist
Who Believes in God,"
is a kind of a countercultural
rebellion against the labels
that our celebrity culture,
our fast moving culture,
likes to give people
as a shorthand
so we don't have to think.
And so when I ran into
that, the wonderful fact
was that being able now to
have an art gallery online
for my paintings-- these are
two out of my spring series
that go together,
and I brought them
because they're
small enough to go
in my carry-on on a airplane.
Come up and take a look
if you want afterwards.
Or whether it was writing
a book that did not
fit with the marketing
strategy of people
who were set in cement since
the 19th century in terms
of the way books are
published and marketed.
The work that you
all are in at Google
has actually opened
the doors up,
and it's very counterintuitive
because I'm a hands-on person.
I only know what I know about
my iPhone and my laptop,
but I'm not
computer-type of person.
Paintings are labor-intensive.
I get honorable dirt
under my fingernails.
This isn't done at a distance
or on a device of some sort.
Writing is not a
high-tech enterprise.
I used to write
longhand on yellow pads,
and my wife would
type this thing up.
And I finally learned how to
type about 20, 30 years ago
and then jumped into computers
and all the rest of it.
But the beauty of the
period of history we are in,
and there is a
real interface here
between Google and the past,
is that we are now at a time
when people are growing
up in a mediated reality.
Children, for instance,
you see on airplanes
who don't have toys or
books or anything else
aren't looking out the window at
the country passing under them
but instead are looking
at some tech device
interpreting the
country for them--
more likely to be looking at
it on a screen than in reality.
But then you get
to people like me
who still earn their living
doing this, real stuff,
that you can feel and
touch that exists only
in one place in time,
which is a one-off thing,
or the trend you see of people
going back to vinyl, collecting
records, or play musical
instruments hands on, busking
in the street, whatever.
And what has happened,
and what my book--
this counter-intuitive title,
"Why I am an Atheist Who
Believes in God:
How to give love,
create beauty, and
find peace," is about
is this kind of
collision of the old
and the new where
the best of the old
is actually
facilitated by the new
because it gives someone
like me a direct access
to, for instance, people I
shipped out to collectors
in Ireland and Switzerland
and all over the US
and other places in
the world that in terms
of a geographical location
I could never touch.
But they can Google me.
They can go online.
They can find me.
And after they get
through all the bullshit
by right-wing activists
about what a horrible person
I am because I came out
of the religious right
and became a traitor,
they eventually
get to some item about
the fact he's a painter.
He's been shown in
this and that gallery.
Or they get to the
fact he's an author.
And they may even
stumble across something
I have actually written instead
of just the invective written
about me or whatever
they might find.
So I'm someone standing here
as a writer and artist who
lives in a very different
world than those of you who
are working for
Google in this room,
and yet you are facilitating
what in actuality would
be perfectly
understandable to an artist
in 15th or 16th century Florence
like Fra Angelico or someone
like that.
That world is now
more alive than it
was in the pre-computer age
when the gatekeepers were
able to shut down any
individual who didn't quite fit.
Painting was supposed
to have disappeared
by now because art critics
in the '50s and '60s
said that post-American
abstract expressionism,
there would be no more painters.
There are more people painting,
more people are drawing,
more people going back to
high-tech draftsmanship
than ever.
And the way they can do
that is because the world is
no longer created and controlled
for art and the humanities
by "The New York Times,"
Harvard, a few art
schools, half a dozen theater
critics, but actually,
is accessible now to everyone.
The downside, of course,
is you've got a lot of crap
out there.
The upside is, however,
when you wade through that
and can make decisions
for yourself,
you now have a world of
creativity at your fingertips
where someone like me who
is an artist and a writer
can access that world
while knowing nothing
about the technology that
facilitates it, but yet can
be there.
One of the great
geniuses of Google
is making things simple enough
and taking the complexity
out without being
condescending to people
like me of another generation
who can come into the Google
world and use it and
have other people use
this to find what we do.
So I want to give you a
little flavor of this book,
talk a little more, and then
open it up for some discussion
because I think we could
have some interesting Q&A
after this.
Let me give you a flavor
of the book in two parts.
First of all, because
I'm a novelist,
I've written novels like
"Portifino," "Saving Grandma,"
"Zermatt," and "And God said,
'Billy!'"-- works of fiction.
I'm a storyteller.
I tend not to put footnotes
in my nonfiction books,
although I footnoted
a long memoir of mine
called "Crazy for God"
because people wanted names
and dates so they would see
I wasn't completely lying
about my unlikely background
of in one lifetime flying round
in Jerry Falwell's
borrowed jet and being
the keynote speakers at the
Southern Baptist Convention.
I'm not kidding you.
23,000 pastors-- this
is in the late '70s.
You've never seen so much
blue polyester in your life,
if you can remember the fashions
in that period of history.
And then fast forward
to the present.
So there's two
aspects to this book.
There's the storytelling,
and then there's
the didactic exposition.
And I'll just give
you one paragraph
from the beginning here
that sort of sets up
a little bit of what the
book is over all about
and give you a touch
of the storytelling
and then talk a little more
and then take questions.
Early on in the book
I write, "Maybe we
need a new category other than
theism, atheism, or agnosticism
that takes paradox and
unknowing into account.
I believe that life evolved
by natural selection.
I believe that evolutionary
psychology explains away
altruism and debunks love
and that brain chemistry
undermines my illusion of
free will and personhood.
I also believe that the
spiritual reality hovering
over, in, and through me calls
me to love, trust, and hear
the voice of my creator.
It seems to me that there is an
offstage and an onstage quality
to my existence.
I live onstage.
But I sense another
crew working offstage.
Sometimes I hear
their voices singing
in a way that's as eerily
beautiful as an offstage chorus
in an opera."
So what I'm trying
to encapsulate there
at the beginning the
book so is to let
people know that
real-life experience not
intellectual ideas about life,
but the actual experience
that you and I have of
life, of love, of tragedy,
of discovering our
sexuality, of parenthood,
of whatever it may be, is always
filled with paradox rather than
certainty.
The only way to get rid of that
paradoxical aspect of your life
is to become a certainty
addict and to flatten out
the questions with an
overall theory of everything,
if you could put
it that way, that
leaves you free to no longer
ask questions that are
inconvenient to your worldview.
But having traveled from
fundamentalist Christianity
to an open and paradoxical
embrace of unknowing
or what was in
history theologically
called apathetic theology, which
was the theology of unknowing
about God, not what you
could say about God,
what you couldn't say.
This actually fits
the way that I have
experienced reality itself.
And I'll give you
an example of that.
I got my wife Genie pregnant
when we were 17 and 18
and had three
children as a child.
Now I'm a grandfather
of five grandchildren
and because I got Genie
pregnant when we were 17 and 18
and my daughter went off to
NYU and got married at 22
and had a baby and
now moved to Finland
and is a high-tech energy
consultant for the European
Union.
See, so I'm not completely
living off in the woods
somewhere getting
people pregnant.
She went off and
got an education
and all the rest of it.
But in comparing the
difference between me then,
this young jerk who was
mean to his daughter
because he was an impatient,
young fool with no knowledge
of parenthood, and
by God's grace,
wound up as a good
friend with his daughter,
but only by grace,
to the person now
who cares for Jack,
Lucy, and Nora,
my three youngest
grandchildren who
live across the street
from me-- ages 7, 5,
and 17 months as a hands-on,
stay-at-home grandfather
most days with those kids while
my son and daughter-in-law go
to work.
And Jeannie and I do child care,
and I get up very early morning
to write.
I always did.
It's no sacrifice,
so my work goes on,
and I paint after they leave.
But those two
people-- I'm 63 now,
and I was 17, 18,
19 then-- that you
can have two totally different
people inhabiting one body
and experiencing life completely
differently in the trajectory
of just one human life.
When I think back
to the certainties
that teenager had
about how to raise kids
and what to do and
discipline them--
at that point of my life, I
was into Calvinist theology
I was raised in that I
was the head of the home,
and my wife should
do what I tell her.
My child should do
what I tell them.
They should be punished and
disciplined-- spare the rod,
spoil the child--
all this nonsense.
And where I am today with my
grandchildren and the pleasure
and delight that I find in
them-- the idea that somehow
these truths are fixed and
related to fixed points
rather than paradoxical learning
curves where you find yourself
at one point of your life
utterly denying and arguing
with yourself at another
point of your life,
if you can understand what I'm
saying-- that this can happen
in one individual
short lifetime, which
is like the lifespan of
a fruit fly after all.
I mean, we're just gone.
We're here instantly and gone.
If I've learned one thing,
it's that the only accurate
description of life's
passage is paradox,
and the only certainty
is uncertainty.
And this doesn't mean everything
is relativistic in the sense
that there's no fixed
points in my life
that I cling to like
these grandchildren.
But it simply introduces
a note of humanity
into the process of trying to
decide who and what you are.
And so I want to read you
this other little passage that
comes from the book to give
you a flavor of this kind
of storytelling element
and where my head is really
having set it up a little bit
more in the argumentative form
earlier.
I take these kids are last year
I did-- Lucy is in second grade
now and Jack is in kindergarten.
But they were both in the same
preschool a couple years ago,
and this comes out
of that experience,
and I think that's the nub
of where I'm coming from,
but also this kind of
human story of learning.
"At first the mothers,"
this is in preschool--
"couldn't figure me out.
What was this old guy
doing hanging around?
Why was he unshaved with unkempt
hair and torn jeans and paint
over his coat?
Shouldn't someone
call the police?"
Because I was picking
them up at preschool.
"After seeing me every day
for a year, the moms know me.
Some know I'm a
writer and artist.
So the paint-spattered
look is accepted.
One mom checked me out
online and discovered
I've been interviewed
by Oprah and Terry Gross
on NPR's "Fresh Air."
Even a minor celebrity is
accorded some eccentric artist
slot, at least in the
arts-friendly Boston area.
I could show up in my bathrobe
and slippers these days
and no one would mind.
I'm just one of the gang,
albeit somewhat of a character.
The mothers and I
discuss one child's cold
and how fast the rest of
us are likely to catch it.
We commiserate about the
latest pinkeye blight.
We talk about one child
who wakes up in the night
and celebrate the quantum
leap another little girl made
with her drawing skills after
discovering chalk pastels.
We know who is pregnant with her
second or third child and share
strategies for helping
the little boy who
was scared of
pooping because he's
sure something is down there.
We congratulate one mom
for finally getting a job
with health care
insurance benefits
and commiserate with another
about the challenging child
care schedule of
the night nurse.
Some of the mothers are
stay-at-home parents,
while others hurry away
from the office at lunchtime
to meet their child, deliver
her to the babysitter,
and race back to work.
Some have told me about problems
with teenage stepchildren,
previous marriages,
divorces, and their struggles
to fit into New England after
moving from a friendlier
part of the country.
Some moms arrive in old cars
while others drive new SUVs.
No matter what we drive
or earn or if we're
married, black, brown, white,
single, gay, heterosexual
or divorced, when we
get down on our knees
at eye level with our babies
as they run into our arms,
we understand each
other perfectly.
The child we're meeting
touches the core of our being.
Every mom delights in the
pint-sized human shouting,
hi mommy.
They shout a greeting that
makes my heart skip is, hi, Pa.
Our shared experience
of vulnerability
erases the age and
gender differences
between the young
mothers and me.
We share a fearful solidarity.
Call it the flip side of love.
If anything awful were to
happen to the child clambering
into our arms, the Universe
as we know it would end."
And that's the truth of human
existence, as I understand it.
It's not some big summary
of theology or philosophy
or marketing strategy.
That's it.
And everything else
is a distraction,
and what's so
interesting to me is
when I was having
lunch today with Josh,
I was trying to
think about what he's
talking about his
struggles with his child,
and I'm talking about
my grandchildren.
And they way I would
put it is this--
at age 63 with
five grandchildren
having had a lot
of striving years.
I was in Hollywood.
I made four feature films.
They were all crap.
But nevertheless, I sat
in the director's chair.
I've had a couple
of bestsellers.
I've done this and that.
That said, I can honestly
say that the core
of the human relationships
that story gets to
is the only part
of my life today
that I have no second
thoughts about.
There's no period of my life
or no activity, no achievement,
or no failure that I look
back on without another point
of view, like maybe this
was just a waste of time.
There was a year when
my kids were little
before I move to the States
from Switzerland when
I spent six months on the road
away from my children doing
stupid things like being at the
Southern Baptist Convention,
sharing the platform with
Ronald Reagan at the Christian
Broadcasters Association,
hanging around people
like Jack Kemp who
was then running
or soon to run for
vice-presidential candidate
for Bob Dole, blah, blah, blah.
At the time, it was all very
exciting and high pressure.
It was a big deal--
all the rest of it.
I look back on that
now as 99% wasted time.
The only glimmer of
hope I have in that
is that I learned from that what
true, unmitigated, unvarnished
bullshit looks like and
can now avoid it better
in the last years of my life.
But that's it.
But when I am with Laura,
who's 17 months old,
and she comes in every morning
and put her arms around my neck
and lays her head
on my shoulder,
and I take care of
her for three or four
blessed hours while Genie
finishes her day's work,
there is not second of that time
that I would trade literally,
and this is not hyperbole, for
anything anyone in this room
or anywhere in the world could
offer me at any given moment,
seriously.
I wouldn't walk away
from 10 seconds with Nora
to guarantee my next book
is a bestseller if that
was the tradeoff.
And if I need to write, I
just get up a little earlier.
This is not altruism.
This is the most selfish
statement I could make to you.
But it's made from a point of
view of actual life experience.
So when I come into
places like Google,
or I talk at writers
conferences, or universities
to a lot of high-powered people.
You've never met more
nervous and unhappy people
than PhD candidates, by the way.
My feeling often is to
try to say, hey, look,
let me give you something
that maybe you're
not expecting in this talk
on the collision of religion
and politics, which is why, for
instance, Rachel Maddow will
have me on.
Let me, as Oprah would say,
share my heart with you.
Do not do as much as I did
in more formative years
that I now look back as
unmitigated, wasted time.
And I'm not talking about
the religious right.
I mean, don't do so
much now that you
will regret when you
get past the hunger
for your striving years
and realize that 99% of it
was bullshit.
You have to have the human
dimension to your life
or you will regret it.
I promise you that.
Now, I know a few
minutes ago, I said
I'm not certain about
anything, and I know I sound
pretty certain about that.
But that's my experience.
And the paradox
of that experience
is this-- the
things that I wanted
most at some parts of my
life actually turned out
to be the most hollow
and meaningless.
The things that I
thought would always
be around like these
children of mine
I had that I didn't pay enough
attention to because I was so
busy doing my hotshot bullshit.
The times with my wife
building a relationship where
I was fool enough to
not realize that the way
that you establish a
relationship with someone
is not going to some
seminar or reading
a book or philosophy
of dating or trying
to meet the perfect person.
It's bringing your lover or
your wife, whomever you're with,
a cup of coffee in
bed in the morning.
It's cleaning up
a little bit when
she's too tired to do that.
Forget the roses and all the
rest of it after a fight.
Have the humility to
say you were wrong.
It's the human
stuff that we take
for granted that
actually takes a lifetime
to get to where you can look
back and see a path that
got you to that place.
And the only thing
I don't regret
about my checkered and stupid
past that if you read the book,
you'll get a little
bit of a hint of
is that it got me to where
I'm standing right now
this afternoon with five
grandchildren waiting
for me who love me, a daughter
who will Skype tomorrow
morning again from Brussels
where she works at the European
Union and who will
tell me where she is.
What I do when I'm
talking here to you guys--
she puts her laptop
where she's talking
and during her talk sometimes
just puts it on Skype
and turns it around
so her dad can
see where she is and
then turns it back,
and we only have a
10-second communication.
That's the moment of my day
that lights up because here's
a child who had
a tough childhood
with a strict, stupid
father, who was a kid
raising a daughter who's
turned into this golden grownup
and who loves me enough to
share a little piece of her life
with me just about every day
to show me what she's up to.
And when I look at that
structure of a day pitching
my new book to my agent.
He's going to be sending it out.
All that stuff matters.
But it only matters the way
footnotes in books matter.
It isn't the real story.
And so this book really
is a couple of things.
It came out a memoir I wrote
called, "Crazy for God,"
and the reason I wrote this
book is that it started when
Christopher Hitchens, the
author before he died,
read "Crazy for God"
and really liked it.
He emailed me a number of
times and started calling me
as he read his way
through it, telling me
he thought it was a
good book, and I'm
a good writer-- all very nice.
And then he got to
the end of the book,
and we had our
last conversation.
He says, I'm really disappointed
because I thought you were now
going to finish the book by
saying you become one of us--
one of us being on the cusp of
the new atheist movement that
was emerging then.
And he said, I
finished the book.
I don't even know
what you believe.
You sort of sound like
a person of faith still.
Why don't you just
take the step?
At the same time, some of
my own evangelical friends
from my past because my
father, Francis Schaeffer,
was this well-known evangelical.
I don't mean well-known
on the street.
I mean, well-known
in his ghetto.
We all have our little
ghettos we live in.
I get emails from them
saying, we love the story.
It's time somebody
told the truth
about the rise of
the religious right
and how it all came about.
But we're very disappointed.
We thought you'd get
to the end of the book
and declare a
straightforward declaration
that in spite of all this,
you're still a man of faith.
Literally, if you
changed a line or two
from my evangelical,
fundamentalist friends
and from my atheist
fundamentalist friends,
it was the same email, and
what was bothering both of them
was ambivalence and paradox
of being able to say, look,
the actual way life
is, is not a series
of watertight conclusions
which now obviate you
from thinking anymore.
One question just
leads to the next,
and it's the overall
experience, and where it matters
is not that you get your
head right with God if you're
an evangelical or get your
philosophy right and march
side by step with Chris
Hitchens or Dawkins.
What matters is
your relationship
with the people in your life,
who you love most about whom
you will regret
nothing except that
you treated them
badly sometimes,
but will look back
and understand
that the actual purpose of
all this other stuff was that.
And so the intellectual
discussion about life
and about its meaning and
about philosophy and theology
masquerades as the
point itself as
if the old evangelical theology
was if you can get your heart
right with God and believe
the correct theology,
you'll be saved, and
otherwise, you're lost.
In my experience,
and what I argue
for-- why I'm an atheist
who believes in God,
and why the book finishes
up with this subtitle, "How
to Give Love, Create
Beauty, and Find Peace,"
is to sidestep
what everyone tells
you are the big questions-- your
career, who you should marry,
when to have children, how
your biological clock is doing,
if you believe in God
or not-- and realize
that the real game and the only
game, and the only thing you
will not regret is the
time you spend not looking
for perfection of belief
or the perfect mate
or when you should have a child,
but to work with what you
have on the human scale
and make that work.
That's it.
That is the only game in town.
In a way, I sometimes
look at the super-wealthy
in our country,
and of course, I'm
not thinking of Donald
Trump right now.
And I say to myself, a great
amount of wealth is actually,
I think, a form, finally,
of mental illness
because the time it takes to
generate that type of wealth,
unless you're just very
lucky as an artist,
and you just get famous because
someone loves your first album
or you invent
something incredible,
and it becomes a phenomenon.
But for the kind of
people who set out
looking for a wealth
as an end in itself,
the energy that demands means
that they have made a trade.
They have trampled on the
relationships that, in the end,
were the whole point
anyway-- many, many times.
I'm not saying for everyone.
So in a sense, someone who's
chased that kind of weatlh--
the kind of person who
really, really, really
wants to head to Wall
Street and make just
a shitload of money-- that's
where their head's at.
This is a form of sickness.
And so our whole definition
of success in this world
is very odd, because we
define mental illness
that we call success according
to the American dream,
as an end in itself that's
worth sacrificing everything
to-- the human relationships.
And so I guess at the
grand old age of 63
and looking at these
grandchildren of mine,
my question is no longer,
how much money did you make?
Did you ever get that PhD
and become a vice-president
of your corporation?
What's your relationship with
your lover and your child?
How much time do you
have in your life
for your grandchildren?
And by the way, does the
word mortality ring a bell?
Did you think this
was going on forever?
And that in turn becomes very
close to the sort of questions
that the prophets in
every religious tradition
asks, whether it's a
religious tradition that
is fastened in something
like Christianity
or a pseudo-religious
tradition of philosophy
that those questions
of character--
those questions of personal
growth, those questions
of having room in your life
for the purpose of life
itself, which is not all
this stuff around you,
but is the actual
experience of love--
the actual experience
of relationships,
of unconditional trust.
These are the things
that all this other glass
and steel we have around us
looking out of this building,
without which,
this is just crap.
And essentially, what
I'm going for here
in the book is saying
that if you begin
from the idea of
paradox and you begin
human relationships
and you begin from the idea
of rejecting these certainties
that you hang everything
on-- get your PhD,
make this much money per
year, wait until you're
this certain age
to have a child,
try to meet the perfect
mate, get rid of the person
you fell love in
with in high school
because it wasn't
the right time,
and now you're 40 and
looking around-- OK,
now you've got all
your ducks in a row.
You step out, and
you're going to try
to get this perfect
relationship going.
That is applying the business
model, which is broken.
It's a mental illness to
the core of life itself
which can't be treated that way
because last time I checked,
we're biological machines
that look at the world
through spiritual eyes.
So we're always at
war with ourselves
because we have this
physical reality.
Yet, we don't see it that way.
I'm a biological machine, so why
would I do something like this?
It has nothing to
do with survival.
I can make money without
selling paintings.
Why do I do this?
Well, these are
the questions that
are unanswerable because our
evolutionary cycle of history
from being
single-celled creatures
until the present coming
out of the material Universe
doesn't really have room for
the need for art and aesthetics
and why somebody would sit
around doing stuff like this
or take all this
time and waste it
by taking care of
their grandchildren
or look back on the successes
and see them as failures
in as much as they were taken
away from the things that
in the end really mattered.
So I'd like to hit you
with those thoughts
and just go back to the theme
that I had at the beginning,
and we'll have a
little Q&A session.
I wanted to read you something.
Obviously, I didn't know
I'd be talking at Google,
so I'm not sucking up to you.
But this is actually
what I wrote.
"A new generation is
embracing human connection
rather than debunking it.
The liberating results are real.
The geeks, bless
them, are killing off
the jaded, cold-hearted
gatekeepers.
When I was young
artist in the 1970s,
I had to travel to a gallery,
slide in a sweaty hand,
and beg for a meeting
with the owner
if I wanted to sell a painting.
If the owner loved my
work, I'd be invited back
a year or two
later, and he or she
would put a few
paintings in a show.
I wandered off into
the movie business
and quit painting and found the
same was true there with script
meetings and all the rest.
When I resumed painting in
2006, I worked for eight years
until I liked my work
enough to show it.
I started a website in 2014
and now sell art directly
to collectors worldwide.
There are no
gatekeepers in sight.
It's just me directly in touch
with people who like my work."
In other words, the
baggage is stripped away
by the technology.
And we get back to the basic
human relationships facilitated
by something that
is inhuman, just
like I'm a biological machine.
But I look at the world
with spiritual eyes.
So here's this weird thing.
Google ought to start
its own religion.
It worked for scientology.
"The same goes for my writing.
I self-published this book.
Given the bestselling status
of some of my previous books,
several of my former
secular publishers
and several religious
publishers were
interested in publishing it.
However, they wanted
me to craft this book
to fit their
marketing strategies.
Does it belong to new atheist or
the religion shelf, they asked.
Can you rewrite it to fit
one or the other market?
My answer was no, yet, you
are reading the book I wrote.
I don't view you as
a market segment.
I view you as my partner, an
individual reader, a friend,
as complex and maybe even
as conflicted as I am.
Why should either of
us fit in anywhere?
My liberators in
Silicon Valley have
freed me to write for
you directly and say
what I want to anyone
when I want to say it.
The internet and its
innovators are doing more
to facilitate the reemergence
of content-laden, craft-rich,
hands-on individuality and
perhaps even spirituality
than all the galleries,
agents, critics, churches,
and publishers combined."
And that brings this
talk to the conclusion,
and we'll have a
couple questions.
And so I would just simply
say, think of the paradox.
The most spiritually
facilitating organizations
in the world are high-tech firms
which deal in ones and zeroes
electronically about as far away
from the human experience you
can get.
And yet, I can sit in my studio
and paint because of that.
I can go directly to a reader.
I can be in my office at any
time I want working online.
I don't have to be in
the Harvard library.
What took me three
weeks before Google,
I can do in three
minutes, literally.
And guess where I can
take that time and use it?
I can play with Nora.
I can be in my front yard as
she picks up wind falls and eats
them off the ground.
And I say, never
mind, worms never
hurt anybody She's enjoying it.
I won't tell her.
We're just primates after all.
She likes this.
So that paradoxical kind
of view of technology
is what I hope people
who work for Google
and other high-tech
companies understand.
And that is, in the
end, what you're doing
is not about science or money.
What you're doing is,
for me, is letting
me play with the granddaughter
because I don't have
to sit in the library all day.
But, and here's the taffy,
the kind of ambitions out
of which things like
Google sprang also
can grind people up in the
same way the movie business can
or the publishing
business or anything else.
And I would urge you to,
especially if you're not as old
as I am, do not trade
in what in the end
will be the things
for your own life
that actually work
for you forever,
combining this biological
animal with this creature who
looks at the world
through spiritual eyes.
Don't trade in that
possibility for yourself
while you're giving someone
like me that opportunity.
That would be a shame.
Find the Nora in your own life.
Find the Genie to
bring a cup of coffee
to in bed in your own life.
Find the thing that
you care about more
than working strategically
within a corporate environment
so that you wind up as a
person and not simply float
with your feet and
your time, as it were,
for the biological
machine, but rather
understand you're also
looking at the world
through spiritual eyes.
And the reason I wrote,
"Why I'm an Atheist Who
Believes in God," is to just
open that discussion up.
So with that,
thank you, and I'll
repeat the questions you ask
so that Josh can get them
on the tape he's
making, and you can
ask about anything you want.
It doesn't have to stick
with the talk here.
Whatever comes to mind.
And we'll take the rest of the
time on a couple of questions
and just feel free to shout them
out or disagree or whatever.
There is an escape
route here if you
didn't like what I was saying.
I can make the door before you
can get to me, polio or not.
So let's go for it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, this
is amusing to me
because it's very similar.
I feel like it's a
very similar path.
I was working in Washington
with a lot of groups
that you probably
criticize on Rachel Maddow.
I got really caught
up [INAUDIBLE].
I decided lets just move
across the country to focus
on family or more
of the personal life
you were talking about
with the ambivalence,
with the loss of either
political or religious ambition
and just saying it's OK
not to know the answer.
Do you ever struggle
for what is the good you
want to do in life, or how do
you bring good into this world
without a very
certain direction?
FRANK SCHAEFFER: Sure, I
think it's a great question.
How do you bring
it into this world
without a certain direction?
If you're all into
ambivalence and paradox,
do you ever donate blood?
Or is that paradoxical
too, so to speak, right?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
FRANK SCHAEFFER: Yeah, and I
would start in bite-size pieces
again without drawing
a huge conclusion.
The first thing I do is that
with my three granddaughters,
they will have known someone
who was a male figure who
loved them unconditionally
and who gave them
the security of
knowing that they are
smart and beautiful and
talented and articulate,
and I am in the corner.
So I will send three young
women into the world who
will make their own choices
and make their own mistakes,
but they will not
look back and say
there was no one there for me.
That I will guarantee.
That's the beginning
of changing the world.
They will be fully operational,
equipped, young women
who at least knew one man who
really had their good at heart,
and that doesn't include their
father, who is also great.
So I'm just starting with that
in terms of what can I do.
My two grandsons I hope will
go into the world understanding
that they had a grandfather
who was humble enough
to apologize when he
yells at them and mean it,
who sends them out knowing that
manhood is not abusing people
and lording over
them, who are not
going to join some fraternity
and think it's a good, fun
thing to get a young
woman drunk and abuse
here because they were
exposed to somebody
who treated them and treated the
women in his life around him,
at least at this age, with
some dignity and respect.
And instead of having a bunch
of crap stuff in the house
talking down to them,
there are open art books
in just about every room.
And I don't think it's normal
to have a child growing up
knowing who all
the superheroes are
who's never heard of Mozart.
I don't think it's normal to
start with Disneyfied pablum
when you have a world of
child literature out there.
So they will have had that.
So I am investing
my time in trying
to be subversive of what I
think are the false values
of an entertainment culture.
Concentrate on the personal.
Concentrate on the
art that lasts.
Go for the good stuff.
Try to get it into their
heads before all the marketers
arrive with the crap.
That's job one.
That's just the grandchildren.
Extend that out to
the grown children
and you are there
for them, and you
are apologizing for
the mistakes you made,
and you are talking
to your wife,
and they see you fight
with her, and you
are backing down and
saying, I'm sorry,
I've been an asshole today, and
you don't mind if they hear it.
So they're growing
up in an environment
where this old idiot has
at least learned something
to pass on to them
by the doing of it.
That to me is interacting
with the world.
And when it comes
to political things,
I was one of the first
bloggers for "Huffington Post."
I have done a lot of
political blogging.
I have two kinds of writing.
The nice guy is here,
and the cage fighter
is in some of my blogs.
For instance, the
one that I wrote
called, "The Slow Motion
Lynching of President Barack
Obama" that had a huge, millions
of reads around the world
and was about the fact
that I'm ashamed to be
a white American in a political
environment that takes
our first African-American
president, who also had more
on his desk on day one
than anybody we've ever put
in the White House,
treated him like shit,
lied about him
consistently, and formed
an entire governmental
opposition to this man based
on rather bring the country
down, risk the economy,
stall the government, default
on our international debts
rather than let him have
any modicum of success.
And so I say what
I think about that
from the platform
of a writer who
has a little big of platform.
Not much-- I'm not famous.
I just earn my living.
That's it.
But I do turn
around and hit hard
when it comes not to
defending my views
but to political views.
Now, right or
wrong, I don't think
that those things can't go
together speaking of paradox.
I think you can be this
grandfather who's concentrating
on what's in front of you.
And at the same time,
you can speak out
and use your platform.
So those would be some of the
things that in my own life,
I try to work together.
Yeah, another question.
Come on.
You all have something
you want to say.
You can't have agreed with
everything I said or liked it.
Throw something.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So I think a lot of
these ideas are really cool,
and they sound good,
especially for people
who work in an office all day.
But I'm just
wondering what do you
think about the other side in
terms of the only people who
go on a different path
and are college dropouts
that you hear from
are the ones who
are really successful like
Mark Zuckerberg or someone
like that.
But the people who go off,
live an alternative lifestyle,
and find that they're not
able to succeed or just
have regrets or disillusionment.
I'm just wondering if you've
experienced that-- if you
have any perspective on that.
FRANK SCHAEFFER: I think
that's a great question.
You only hear success
stories, alternative stuff.
Remember, I came
out of the '60s.
So I know all about how
countercultural alternatives
turn out.
And they usually don't.
But I'm not talking so much
about dropping out of a system.
I'm talking about
carving a life out
within that where you get
your priorities straight.
It's up here.
It isn't out there.
So the fact of the matter is
the first business at hand
is to decide what we really care
about as an individual whatever
the environment is
whether it's in an office,
whether it's in an corporation,
you're a freelancer,
you're a writer,
self-unemployed,
as I call myself--
whatever it may be.
That factor doesn't
change how we
relate to another human being.
And this is why I'm
still so interested
in spirituality, and
most particularly,
the example of Christ.
And my atheist friends
will hate that I just
said Christ instead of
Jesus because that intimates
you think he's the Son of God.
So, hey, looking
into the camera here.
Stop being so theological.
I was raised the
way I was raised.
So I'll call him Christ
if I damn well want to.
But the fact of
the matter is when
you look at the teaching
of Jesus who has never
the law with, he always said,
well, here's what the law says,
and then he had this
big word he uses.
But here's what I said use.
So the law says
throw these stones
at this woman
caught in adultery.
But here's what I'm telling you.
The law says when he talks to
this American woman-- I have
some of this in the book--
we shouldn't even be talking
together because I'm a
Jew, and you're [INAUDIBLE]
and this is like Jesus
meeting a leader from ISIS.
Really, they hated each other.
We shouldn't even be
on the same mountain.
She is saying, we
shouldn't be talking.
He says, none of this matters.
The day is coming
when it's not going
to be an issue of the law
but truth and spirit--
exactly what I'm
talking about here.
So I think that our battle
is not where we work.
Our battle is not our career.
Our battle is not whether
you're working in an office
or drop out and live this
fanciful, Mark Zuckerberg,
whatever it is, life.
I think our battle genuinely
is a spiritual battle.
And it's the battle to see
other human beings as we
see ourselves first and not
to see everybody around us
as useful tools to climb
something that, in the end,
turns out to be
totally self-defeating
because while climbing
it, we have ignored
the real thing that would
have given our life purpose
and meaning.
So I don't think this
battle is won or lost
by people who are conventional
or unconventional or corporate
or artistic.
The most people creative in
the world right now are working
often in corporations like
Google, like Microsoft,
like Facebook .
It isn't a question
of the artist types
and the spiritual types
versus the creative types
versus the business types.
There's an amalgam
there, and that's
another paradoxical truth.
So I would just say,
spirituality really matters.
This is one place
I totally get off
the boat with the new
atheist movement that
boils all down to
science and fact
in the same way
that fundamentalists
of the Christian Right boil
it all down to theology,
taking America back--
blah, blah, blah, blah.
I think we have to come up with
a different vocabulary that
bypasses these surface
differences-- who
works in an office, who's gay,
who's straight, who's black,
who's white-- who's
a grandfather, who's
never had any kids?
And understand, there's
a much deeper truth
we're all going for, and
that is our relationship
with human beings around
us, and through them,
the world around all of us.
And that's something that's a
matter of how we see things.
Now, weirdly enough, that
also leads to a create life.
And I think the two
things go together.
So that may not be a
full enough answer,
but it's the best I can do.
Yeah?
Another question.
AUDIENCE: So it seems
to me that you're really
making a comment here about
human element and that
[INAUDIBLE], and that
we shouldn't really live
in these different extremes.
But when we look
at our government,
we have the guns, religious,
Republican views--
all the stuff.
Then we have the far Left.
What are your thoughts on that,
and how do we break this cycle
and get out of this
packaging that everything
has to sit in today?
FRANK SCHAEFFER: Well, I think
one way the cycle gets broken,
and I promise you
I'm not doing this
because of where-- because of
this-- the Google thing here.
But the availability of
information and choice is huge.
So one of the big
generational shifts--
it's not an accident,
for instance,
that the attitudes towards gay
men and women and transgender
and transexual
people has changed.
Sure, there is some
cultural impetus.
Sure, there was some
entertainment and some TV
programs that humanize people.
But the real thing
is the same phenomena
that you find in a family
where someone is gay
or they know someone who's gay,
and it's like wait a minute,
it isn't them anymore.
It's my friend Joe over
here or my daughter whoever.
The humanizing of the
other is the battle today.
other is our battle today.
And the question is,
how do we do this?
Well, Google is doing it simply
by putting the information
out there.
It's not achieving
the final result.
That's up to individual
human beings.
But it's hard to demonize people
you know a click away when you
can have their life, and their
picture, their story-- whatever
they're putting on YouTube.
It's tough to demonize them
because now we know them
intimately in a way
two generations ago,
no one could know
anyone who didn't
spend a lifetime researching.
So the intimacy of the
information highway
is one of the great things
we can look for to help us.
This has to continue.
And what we mustn't
allow to happen,
and this is my own
humble opinion,
I'm certainly not an expert, is
commercializing the information
highway to the point
where it looks like you're
being conned when you go on it.
This will poison us.
This will poison us because
we need to keep it idealistic.
We have to have accessibility.
So I think that's
one huge point.
and the second point I
think that's happening
is that I'm not pessimistic.
I think there's a generational
shift taking place.
The anger you see gathered
around Donald Trump--
these insane people who--
Mexicans are rapists.
And we've got to build walls.
All this horrible, and may I
just say it, un-American filth
of fascist crap.
It's not American.
This is not in our tradition.
Well, sure, it's Jefferson
being a slave owner.
It's very American.
But it's not the
America we all want
to think we're part of-- this
circle the wagons attitude.
The only way to combat that is
for the succeeding generation,
the younger people, to simply
hold in their long enough
for these idiots to
begin to go away.
And when you look
at, for instance,
who Fox News's basic viewer
is, he's a guy my age.
And he is like me, not going
to be around as long as some
of the younger
people in this room,
although I intend on being.
So I think there's a
generational shift coming.
I wouldn't get too terribly
pessimistic right now.
I think there really is.
And I think the
fury you see in ISIS
and the fury you
see in the Taliban
and this horror of destroying
the great cultural monuments
of North Africa in the name
of Islam, all this stuff,
or why people would
coalesce around
a Donald Trump and his
hate-filled language
and the whole Republican
effort to try to shut down
President Obama over
these last years,
actually, there's an
encouraging part to that,
because in my experience
of human life,
anyway, you don't get
that level of passion
from people who feel
secure and that they're
on the winning side.
They know they're losing.
The demographics are shifting.
This country will be brown,
and we are becoming younger
in terms of our attitudes and
gay people will get married,
and it doesn't matter
whether somebody
says she won't give
a marriage license
or Donald Trump comes along.
It's sound and fury
signifying nothing.
It's damn hard to
live through if you're
looking toward a future.
But, actually, and I know you
don't hear this too often,
but I'm very optimistic
about the future of North
America in so many ways.
As I go around talking in
schools and universities,
I don't meet hate-filled people.
I talk to people who
are open to others
most of the time,
who want to live
lives that incorporate others.
Attitudes are changing, and I
think the information highway
has a lot to do with
that, and I think,
as I've said in the book,
one of the things I say
"Why I'm an Atheist
Who Believes in God"
is one of the paradoxes
in my own life
is that the most spiritually
alive place right now is,
you could say, the least
traditional and the least
spiritual in that it's also,
again, the internet highway.
The discussion I have
on my Facebook page.
I happen to answer all
the messages I get.
I happen to answer
all my emails.
I try to take that human
element into a discussion
with my readers.
It's one reason I
enjoy being a writer.
It's being facilitated,
paradoxically,
by something that doesn't
seem to have anything
to do with spirituality,
and yet it really does.